we're at the very beginning of the month
of may so it's time for me to produce
another update video in which I talk
about what went on during April and what
we've got coming up in in may for those
who are interested as usual I want to
begin by highlighting three big things
one of which is not actually about may
itself although some of it is going to
happen in in May but really extends
further into the year so big thing
number one this is a really big thing
for us here at reason I oh and for
myself we started our first Aristotle
class Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
offered online yesterday on the first
and why this is really big news is I've
taught for a lot of institutions and you
know some of them have been traditional
colleges and universities some of them
have been you know online platforms that
are engaged in innovation this is the
first one that we're actually offering
for our ourselves through ourselves on
our own just myself and my my wife and
partner Andy Chaka who are the
principles of reason I oh so I'll talk a
little bit more about that I guess when
when we get to the may section second
big thing that I want to put on your
radar if you're in the Milwaukee area or
you know even in southeastern Wisconsin
at all you might want to consider coming
to my lecture tomorrow night at the
frank Weinberg library in in mequon I'm
going to be talking about Saint Anselm
somebody who I've published a lot on and
done a lot of presentations on over the
years and I'm talking about his place in
historical context i'm going to be
talking about his own works in life in
the light of what was going on in Europe
at the time which includes among other
things the norman conquest of england
and the after effects of that
the third big thing is that you can look
in this month for some important
announcements that will be coming out as
a matter of fact one of them should be
coming out this weekend about stoic on
which is the the conference for
international stoic week this year it's
actually going to be hosted in New York
City I'm going to be one of the speakers
I'll actually be doing a pretty long
workshop on stoicism and anger and how
you can apply stoic principles to deal
with anger whether your own or other
peoples in your life so look for those
announcements there's a lot of back-end
work that has to happen in order to make
these things you know take place on the
right date way off at October so we're
already engaged in a lot of planning
rate right now so what went on in the
month of April that we've just gotten
through I thought it was actually going
to be a relaxed month didn't turn out to
be quite like that in part because i was
comparing it to march where I did four
or five talks I think five if i remember
right i only had one talk lined up for
for april and that was the talk on CS
Lewis's space trilogy in the philosophy
and speculative fiction series it hosted
at the brookfield public library here
here in the southeastern Wisconsin area
I also did a half-hour Hagel Q&A session
public Q&A session through google
hangouts I do that monthly as a way of
giving back since people are in fact
supporting me through patron to do these
half hour Hagel videos what the month
turned out to be a lot busier than I had
expected one thing that's kind of cool
that happened is I'm now booked for
giving some some more library talks in
march i gave a talk at the Shorewood
public library on mary wollstonecraft
and i gave a talk at the iowa tosa
public library
on existentialism both of them have you
know great a great attendance and and
they said we'd love to have you come
back so I've arranged to get some things
on the calendar with them one in July
one in September the goal is to have no
more than two of these talks each month
and not have them pile up like they did
in in March so that's cool I spent a lot
of the month building the Aristotle
class that I'm now teaching there's a
lot of back end work that goes into
designing online courses and so you know
that's that's what I've been involved
and it's been a lot of fun because I
enjoy talking about and thinking about
and producing resources on Aristotle
I've also been continuing to work on the
anger management curriculum for priority
thinking things have gone through a lot
of iterations and we feel that we're now
getting fairly close to a finished
product which is really cool um stoicism
today you know since taking over as
editor in March I've been soliciting
pieces and editing and sending some back
to the people and saying and not quite
what we're looking for can you tweak it
a bit I've also written a piece starting
a new series that I'm going to be
continuing month to month on the stoics
and anger you know I think that's an
important topic that they can help us
out with quite a bit I did quite a bit
of philosophical counseling and tutoring
some academic coaching some executive
coaching so a lot of client stuff a lot
of you know carried out by some
face-to-face some by skypes on my phone
you know it's quite a lot to do but I
really enjoy that that work I did get
some writing done not as much as i would
have liked and particularly not as much
as i would have liked in my blogs which
i had started to gain some momentum back
with and and now I've got to you know
start pushing the cart a bit more
forward so hopefully in
eh i did also managed to get some
back-end website stuff done as well that
needed to be done for reason I oh and
with YouTube finally got those to
WordPress and YouTube to play together
right they don't make it that easy to
figure out exactly how that's supposed
to be done but I did it and so now I can
start integrating those a bit more
closely so that people who are watching
a video can you know um you know find
out about what what services we offer on
unreason I oh that might support their
learning video work I only managed to
shoot five half hour Hagel videos I
actually shot footage for four more but
I didn't shoot all of the footage that's
needed for for the last video and so I'm
just waiting on some time to do that I
did start doing the core concept videos
on st. Anselm's Mona Logan and quite a
few people have been enjoying those
Anselm takes you through some real
twists and turns of argumentation did a
video that I actually released a video
that I had done earlier for my Patrian
subscribers Patrian backers rather and I
released it publicly on the process of
producing half-hour Hagel videos and
gives you a little inside look into how
I make the videos and what's involved in
video production in general I also
released the the video from the talk in
Virginia at Virginia Commonwealth
University what can analytic and
continental philosophers learn from each
other which was shot on the 31st but
then released a bit later and there's
the video of the CS lewis session at the
brookfield public library as well what
have we got coming up in May May is
going to be a pretty busy month I'm
trying to get ahead of things for once
in part because during the summer
there's a lot of family things that go
on that that can consume quite a bit of
time so I want to try to
get as much done ahead of time as
possible rather than simply scrambling
got three events coming up during May
that you may be interested in like I
said at the very start I've got to talk
on an some the church and the Norman
Conquest that is going to be you know I
think a lot of fun to do and hopefully
I'll get some really great questions
it's a topic that I've been you know
thinking about for a very long time
because of a big fan of st. Anselm that
is may third at six o'clock at the frank
Weinberg library in mequon the week
after that we have another one of these
speculative fiction and philosophy talks
at the brookfield Public Library May
tenth at seven o'clock that's a thursday
night and then we have our half hour
hagel question-and-answer hang out free
open to the public any sort of hegel
related issues or questions confusions
that you want to bring up I will tackle
them that is May twenty-fifth on
Wednesday five o'clock central time or
Chicago time if you're if you're looking
at it you know through one of those
international drop-down menus that runs
for an hour so you want to get there at
five o'clock and we give precedence to
those who have questions ready what else
is going on in May quite a lot so I'm
teaching the Aristotle course which we
have about three quarter enrolled which
is pretty good because we didn't really
do much of the way of advertising I just
shot a YouTube video and put some stuff
up on facebook and twitter and google+
and linkedin even this time but we've
got a lot of really committed learners
great discussions already going on we
held our first introductory class
session yesterday and so there's there's
all of that I'm developing a lot of
resources for this course many of which
have already been done
some of which I'm still in the process
of developing working on the the anger
management curriculum for priority
thinking like I said that is actually
we're in sort of the last iterations of
that we're very happy with that and as
the editor of Stoicism today I've got a
lot of work to do with that with some
organizational things with soliciting
more blog posts from from you know guest
writers with coordinating all of the
stuff that's going on in terms of stoic
on and the stoic mindfulness and
resilience training and the stoic week
course all those things although I'm not
myself thank thankfully having to
organize them all of those need to be
publicized in stoicism today so I work
with the project team to do that sort of
stuff also be writing some some posts
you should probably see maybe one a
month by me in this this series on
stoicism and anger this month i'm also
going to try to build out more content
in curious which is that that platform
that i've already created several mini
courses in we're also getting another
longer course through reason I all ready
to run in the early summer probably in
mid-june after the Aristotle course is
done that is going to be Plato's
symposium which I taught before quite a
few you know students really enjoyed the
course got a lot out of it so I'll be
you know talking a bit about that later
in the month maybe I'll shoot a video on
it or any way keep keep your eyes open
because I'm going to be publicizing that
that course so if you're interested in
studying Plato's symposium with somebody
who has been reading it and rereading it
for about 20 years maybe you might
consider that course lots of marketing
and outreach stuff that I need to do
there's there's a number of different
sectors of places where I could
giving talks and I and and people have
been giving me recommendations you need
to talk to this person this person and I
need to really get on that it's not
something that I am particularly
enthused about doing I'm much more
interested in content and and you know
one-on-one conversations but if you're
somebody like me who does a lot of
public speaking it really is quite
important to get out there and you know
start sending press kits and and
inquiries and all that the organizations
in the area so that's that's part of
what I'll be doing this month some
academic writing I've got to get a piece
that I've got more or less done on an
some finished on an some prayer and
mercy and justice I've got a lot of
Aristotle writing to do in addition to
getting ready for a conference
presentation that i'll be doing in June
on Aristotle achrafieh and anger I'm
also working on a book right now a short
book on Aristotle and the virtues then I
will probably end up self-publishing one
of the perks of the students who are
enrolled in the Aristotle classes
they're going to get first look at that
and a free copy of it once once it's
finished a little bit of writing I've
got to do on Marcel as well and I'm
hoping to get some more blog entries
written and released this month on at
least our exes do you know NTK and half
hour Hagel because you know that's
something that I want to keep going
video work so I've got my normal quota
of six half hour Hagel videos to try to
get done I'm going to be continuing the
anselm core concept videos were really
only about half way through the material
of the Manolo Geum that I want to try to
cover and after that we're going to do
the pro slogan and after that we're
going to do his day very taut a or on
truth which is a very interesting work
you should see some videos from the
talks the
on an some in the talk and Asimov coming
out and I'm also shooting although
you're not going to see these this month
but probably later in the summer a lot
of new Aristotle core concept videos for
the Aristotle course last week I shot 20
core concept videos on Aristotle 20 a
lot of video work so that's been keeping
me quite busy I still have i would
estimate probably another 30 that i will
be shooting over the course of this
month some of them this week but i'm not
going to be releasing them until after
the aristotle course has finished my
students get first crack at those videos
and after all of the an some work is
done so you'll see those later on in the
summer that's pretty much yet for me
doesn't sound like too much does it and
yeah we've got like I said you know a
lot of interesting projects going on
here I'm very fortunate in that I am
never bored there's always worth enough
work for me to do and I will probably
never have to think about retirement
because there's always going to be more
and more work to come down the line the
only problem is I can't get it all done
or done to my specifications all right
so that that's enough for this month I
hope that you have a good month ahead of
May and if you're interested like I was
talking about with the the marketing
until I axe if you're interested in in
talking with me about booking a talk or
a workshop or a discussion or anything
along those lines go ahead and email me
at Greg at reason I o.com and i'll be
happy to discuss it we've got some cool
stuff happening towards the fall in
terms of talks but i'll talk about that
more in other videos alright so signing
off have a great month